hi I'm Josh I'm one of the community
managers on Transformers Universe and
this is our brand new show under the
hood
we build up to launch and beyond we will
be here to make sure that you are up to
speed and ready for battle will be
introducing you to the team showing you
around and giving you exclusive
behind-the-scenes access coming up in
today's show I'll be taking some of your
questions directly to the developers the
community team will be talking about the
newly announced founders program and you
can win one of our exclusive
Transformers Universe jackets but first
let's take a peek at the gadget show
this was the first time the public went
hands-on with the game and they really
enjoyed it I'm smaller and I would have
septic on come on over no one wins by
being a good guy ever I've been good our
freaking food or and it looks a bit
I'm an Autobot I'm a Decepticon wait
wait wait wait wait wait we can't do
that is badass next up on the
Transformers Universe tour is MCM London
so if you can get yourself down there
we'd love to meet you a few weeks ago we
held an event down in London where the
world's gaming media had a first look at
the game and he also got their chance to
ask their questions you may have seen
some previews online but here under the
hood it's your turn so I've grabbed a
few of your questions off the forum and
I'm going to go get them answered
first question comes from turbine and he
wants to know where does transformers
universe fits into the transformers
timeline oh right great questions our
line yet so stylistically the game has
evolved to fit in with in what has
recalled the transformers generations
timeline we've worked really closely
with Hasbro obviously over the
development of the game and we feel
we've given the game its own natural
vibe and feel but as it involves it will
continue in what transformers fans will
recognize as the transformers
generations okay cool the next one comes
from the night raider and he wants to
know what other modes apart from
elimination can we expect at launch
alright great while op's enjoying
elimination but we've also got meteor
storm which is a mode where you're
fighting against the other function to
locate capture and defend resource hubs
you can also go into the outer base and
carry out some of the public missions
we've set out there for use you can
mining Energon you can be killing
terrorcons we've also got the crisis
mode already again in beta where you can
team up with allies on your faction and
go out and take on specific missions and
quests to complete out there I have a
tricky one here for a motion dragon
what's the long-term plan for
transformers universe yeah great
question so obviously very difficult to
cover that in the short video segment
but we've got a you know at least a 15
year roadmap for this project I want to
build a hobby so there's lots of
different things for people to play you
when you're thinking about playing
Transformers Universe there's always
something view to come and do the called
transformers universe for a reason at
the moment we're on earth but the brand
in the IP opens up to us so many
possibilities so many different places
we can go off-planet and we can
introduce new modes and you new schemes
and new ways of play
so Nick had a lot of people on the
forums asking about vehicles what will
be available at launch to start with
we're going to be on their ground-based
vehicles got monster trucks motorbikes
sports cars off-road vehicles suvs we
trucked military vehicles and then going
forward after launch we're looking at
bringing the stuff that everybody wants
so you tracked vehicles hovercrafts and
flight obviously okay and what you're
looking forward to yourself the most I'm
gonna go to the tractor vehicles I want
to get tanks in there and then obviously
with that later on down the line you
know it becomes guys like a blitz main
wall parts cool and then got a question
from dead put and he wants to know about
how he'll be working with familiar
characters in the game okay so mentors
won't fill out a couple of functions so
we've got guys in the innovation social
areas and then in your specific mission
arenas and battle areas then you've got
mentors giving you a mission critical
information going forward or we want the
players to also be able to pick up there
well known and well loved characters and
play those as well but we're talk about
today and then final question is from
star warp and he wants to about
customization how can you make this
boy's own okay so we've got a couple of
ways of split into things that affect
how the bot can perform and how they
look so to start with you get the base
paint job of a warrior and you can tweak
that but we've also got full-on skins
which change the model or the silhouette
of the bot we've also got big full-scale
redos and then as far as I actually
changing how wats function we've got a
wide variety of stuff from changing
stats like bot speeds damage
regeneration that kind of thing and then
alcohol as prototypes and all meds as
well so I think what we're going is a
bit more detail on those at a later date
that yes there's a lot there to kind of
make the bought your own yeah absolutely
so it's not just visual there's there's
a huge amount of depth in their
increasing your bottom and making them
more effective on film thanks Nick I'm
now going to pass you over to the rest
of the community team are going to be
talking about founders
so the founders program is a great way
of giving yourself a nice head start the
game as well as access to a few
exclusives that won't be available to
others at launch we have four packs to
choose from and each of those packs
contain a bunch of awesome things such
as in game relics title and avatar for
the forum you will be immortalized on
the website which is pretty awesome and
you will also receive a season pass the
silver gold and cybernet packs will also
contain access to some pretty cool new
warriors that will only be available to
founders owners at launch as well as a
selection of items that will help give
you sort of boosts and a helping hand in
game you will receive up to six new bots
three Autobots and three Decepticons the
osh bots are anomaly ripped raw and
double tape and the Decepticons you will
get derail dead heat and Australia with
the Cybernet pack you will also gain
access to all 18 bots at launch as well
as some exclusive cyber night skins and
the best part about cyber night is that
you will receive a limited edition
Transformers Universe figurine we only
have a few cybernetic packs available so
visit the website to check out which
pack suits you the best and you can
become a founder too and we hope to see
you on the forum soon thanks guys before
we go I did promise you a competition
and skate your hands on one of these
limited edition jackets all you need to
do is simply share this video on your
facebook or twitter using the hashtag
test your mettle i would announce the
winner shortly on the next episode of
under the hood we have something special
for you one shall stand one shall fall
to make sure you don't miss that
subscribe to our channel and we'll see
you next time
you
you